the mysterious benedict society
premiering this friday on disney plus
with two episodes he plays not only one
but two characters
in this show that i can't wait to watch
with my kids he is tony hale the emmy
award winner
how are you tony hey guys how are you
i'm doing here you got such glow but i'm
sorry you got such blowback about your
well your sports tony when was the last
time you saw the karate kid tony hill
what was the last time
you saw that um it's been a well it's
been a long time
my choice would be is goonies a sports
movie
[Laughter]
i don't know what what would this what
would the sport and goonies
be i don't even know how well oh my god
how do you say that's another sport did
you see the adventure they went on
the amount of physical activity they had
it did involve bicycling kind of like
you know uh of spielbergian breaking
away
i i think i'm it did sorry immediately i
thought no that was e.t
that's right that's true that's true
again it was eta sports movie because
the bike could fly tony you know what i
mean like yeah
i mean they might be in the category but
they did a lot of fun stuff in that
movie i mean that was my sport i was not
a sports kid so
goonies was my highlight it's funny i
showed my
children goonies and because one of my
uh
one of my uh individuals in my close
circle
tony said show it to your kids i showed
it to my kid they were they were
freaking out they were losing their mind
they were not that
i mean they were like what that my
nine-year-old and my six-year-old were
losing their minds
that's not a kid's movie that's not a
kid's movie anymore well it's also
i mean do you mean the dead body falls
on
um who is the the the uh
gosh the kid who ate all the time
yeah yeah dead body fell on top of
chunks right that was the most
terrifying it was a frozen dead body
falling on top of them that was
terrifying
right so uh when when we sit down and my
children
sit down and watch the mysterious
benedict society where are we cool we're
good
is that this is gonna be good yeah
you're totally cool there's gonna be no
frozen dead bodies falling on top of
little children robert davie's not gonna
appear and is is an
evil character the actor robert dotto no
he's not going to show up well
no well um no but uh not the mystery
freddie i'm i'm very excited for people
to see it sorry
i i wish i was there in person so we
wouldn't have to deal with technology
like this this is fine
this is working so you play you play two
two characters in this i do the show
i do okay i play uh i play twins
and one's name is mr benedict one is
curtain and
i don't like to say good guy evil guy i
think i think the evil guy is
misunderstood
but um it was really fun it was it was a
real challenge i mean i'm really excited
for everybody cx it's a very adventurous
fun show and it's just great
yes and you know just for those who
might be because you're you're not
seeing us right now and for our radio
audience
the the uh benign uh character you play
is the gentle bearded smiling one and
the evil one you put in there
you've got like the turtleneck sport
coat uh beard
thing going on that's the evil look
that's the way you go evil in this
yeah because turtlenecks and sports
coats are very dark
it's a choice it's it's definitely a
choice there's no question about that
um yeah but it was i mean you know i
think the the actors on this show are
very very small piece of the pie most of
the pie is made up of hair makeup
wardrobe production design
like there's a lot of work that went
into this and it's pretty fantastic
really fantastic so uh is the was this
the first
post-veep thing that you did is this the
first thing
okay yeah um well i uh i do
okay no i did a i did a play last spring
in san francisco which was really fun
and then i think i did another good but
yeah this was kind of the first show
and so um i went from a show that my
child has never seen to a show that my
child can't see
i was about to ask if you you know is if
if you wanted to
go in the uh polar opposite direction of
veep
that this was the choice was that the
choice that you made
tony yeah i mean it was no it was i mean
i was of course excited to play twins
but it was very weird because
i think my purpose got bigger because
the show
starts off and there's a global crisis
called the emergency happening
yes that's sending all these negative
messages and all this noise and putting
people in a state of panic and
we were in the middle of a pandemic and
then i find these kids
to send i send these kids out to kind of
find the source and these kids don't
have magical powers
their superpowers are empathy their
intellect and creativity
and it's like man after the year we've
had those are the voices
that you know raised to the top so it
was pretty wild
the parallel that i was finding while
doing it yeah and plus you
i know uh one of the times that you've
been on previously tony you talk about
your children's book that you wrote
archibald's next big thing so
this kind of this kind of works the
whole thing kind of works all together
yeah yeah and it was really it was
really fun and i i'm just
super excited for people to see it it's
an absolutely beautiful show disney
whole family the whole family so again
this is not going to be like a goonies
experience where i'm going to turn it on
and they're going to be like dad what
the hell is your problem
and somebody's going to stroll in at 3
30 in the morning and just have a
problem for a week straight that won't
happen
essentially no this isn't going to hurt
this isn't going to provide any
nightmares
okay and i was that kid that had my my
brother i think showed me nightmare on
elm street or something he's like that's
not that bad
i thought i thought those hands were
going to reach
at me under my bed like i was convinced
those knives were going to come and get
me like two in the morning right
that's why you uh you're always cutting
your fingernails uh that's that's that's
me at least
exactly i have a tear of nails
i actually took them all off i don't
have any nails i'm not i'm not really
i'm i'm not really a
horror movie guy anyway tony i'm not
either rich let me tell you why
because there's so much fear in our
world why are we gonna sit in a room and
be scared just watch cnn i'll be just as
scared
are you calling are you calling jake
tapper the freddie krueger of
of news television tony is that what you
just did you didn't
hear it from me but no i love jake now i
know that well i do too with the
exception of he's he's a uh he's a
die-hard christmas truther are you
as well tony what do you think is die
hard a christmas movie tony
oh oh is that where it came from yeah oh
yeah
is die hard a christmas movie um
it's not in my category of christmas
movies that's why i love talking um
i love tony but is it is it just because
there was like a tree in the back corner
i can't even remember the movie
no he's jake will say and again i
just uh uh you know be fair about it
because again we
we talked about this yesterday with the
whole what makes a sports movie what has
to be
you know what what are the concepts of a
sports movie to call it such
and what's a christmas movie to me
there's got to be something about the
christmas spirit
and a terrorist blowing the roof off of
nakatomi plaza to me in a
movie called die hard that comes out in
the summer does not strike me as
christmas just because they're playing
christmas carols and it's on christmas
eve
but jake will say that um you know uh
uh john mcclane's wife was called holly
they shot the glass out and he starts
bleeding which
is similar to stigmata um yes
i mean and and that you need to ask him
what was what he considers an easter
movie
what he considers a valentine's movie i
mean i would be very interested in his
feedback for that right karate kid is a
halloween movie
as far as i'm concerned you know exactly
exactly
elf is the perfect christmas movie to me
that is a christmas movie
because go for it because it has holiday
spirit
you walk away from the feeling you walk
away from the theater feeling joyful
and hopeful and ready to celebrate with
family
i don't think i have those i think i
enjoyed die hard but i don't think i
walked away with like a joyous hey let's
hug
right after them you're not buzzing
because the angel who got his wings
isn't you know uh john mcclane john
mclean because he saved the building
which is a miracle
in a self-story of discovery and
redemption
which is what the christmas spirit is
all about i i fully agree with you tony
okay thank you this is why we you know i
like having you on not only because i
appreciate you but you echo my beliefs
that's why i'm also told before to echo
your beliefs i'm not supposed to say
is that was that part of the
pre-interview i didn't know that tony
i'm not supposed to mention do that to
you but that's the truth
okay um where where's where is buster
bluth today do you think
tony where is he today oh rich
oh buster buster is probably
uh in the corner somewhere counting his
pharmaceuticals
and just uh polishing his hook do you
think
buster do you think buster would go on
lego masters what do you think of that
what do you think with william i mean
with will arnett what do you think would
he be a lego master guy
what if the legend if the legos had a
magnet that he could
attach to his hook i mean that would be
quite difficult
but i think he's probably got really
good with that right hand yeah he could
he could he could make a lego structure
of course will arnett hosts lego masters
i know that
that job connection that's why that's
why i ask because it's just i love
seeing will out there as sort of like a
reality show host
looking mysterious and standing over
people making them nervous about
building stuff with lego
my kids watch that too actually i can
see i can see buster building something
up and then just
joe just coming down just going what's
this and just crap
[Laughter]
you know will arnett would like to do
that too in real life right like
somebody just like
go up to them 100 that would be his joy
see now you know this is exactly why
this is why i want more uh healthy fare
for my children that's what they watch
they do love lego masters we're watching
uh you know masked singer and things
like that you know like that's the sort
of stuff that we're watching
i'm i'm looking for something with a
narrative something with a narrative and
a story
and also what i what i love about uh
benedict society is do you like it like
we we've gotten into escape rooms lately
where you kind of go in and use like all
these puzzles are trying to figure out
there's so many mysteries and puzzles
within the show
that these kids have to figure out it's
a really fun activity to figure
uh kind of take that challenge this is
great all right so they will not be
afraid of mr curtin they will not be
like coming in
no no no no no no they will not be
afraid of mr curtin you're not going to
see any freddy krueger
not at all tony hale you're you're
again uh that is a heck of a
well-tailored jacket
dicky look that you've got working on
right there man that is
oh that is thank you and by the way i
like the the parenthetical word
nefarious i like
all of it i like the whole vibe that
you're giving out so that's a big word
and they'll learn they'll learn thanks
for the call tony hale you take care of
yourself
let's do this again in person we'll do
this the next time yes thank you sir
check it out the mysterious benedict
society premiering this friday
on disney plus with two episodes hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here